son va maintenant partir aux états unis
à washington retrouver notre
correspondante sonia dridi bonjour à
vous sonia joe biden a pris la parole
dans la foulée de celle du président
russe il dénonce je cite une attaque
injustifiée de la russie contre
l'ukraine voilà pour les mots maintenant
comment s'organise actuellement
concrètement la réponse occidental
alors oui jo by dane a publié un
communiqué dans lequel il a dénoncé une
attaque injustifiée de la russie il a
assuré que le monde allait exiger des
comptes de la part de la russie joe
biden qui a annoncé qu'il allait
s'entretenir ce jeudi matin avec ses
homologues du g7 et il va ensuite
s'exprimer devant les américains
normalement à midi heure de washington
18h15 de paris il devrait annoncer dans
ce discours quelles seront les
conséquences pour la russie a tué lana
cette attaque un de l'ukraine joe
à l'eau excusez moi ça a coupé il a
annoncé que quelles seront donc les
conséquences pour la russie de cette
attaque il doit on a appris aussi qu'il
s'était entretenu avec le président
ukrainien il y à peu et il s'est aussi
entretenu avec le secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken et avec son ministre de
la défense
alors on a senti la tension monte un ces
dernières heures parce que peu avant
cette attaque de la russie en ukraine le
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken a prévenu qu'il pourrait y avoir
une invasion d'envergure de l'ukraine
avant l'aube et les états unis on le
sait cela fait des semaines un qu'ils
préviennent qu'il pourrait y avoir une
attaque d'envergure de l'ukraine
washington qui a d'ailleurs émis en
place une stratégie innovante en
dénonçant ces dernières semaines et en
révélant les plans de vladimir poutine
en espérant disait des officiels de la
maison blanche en espérant déjouer ces
calculs alors pour l'instant
la maison blanche a réagi avec des
sanctions face à ce qu'ils appelaient
depuis lundi le début d'une invasion de
l'ukraine ce mercredi joe biden a
annoncé des sanctions notamment contre
north stream ii et ses dirigeants il
aussi annoncé des sanctions financières
contre des banques russes contre les
élites russes il devrait donc annoncer
de nouvelles sanctions la maison blanche
a prévenu qu'elle allait ajuster ses
sanctions en fonction de l'évolution de
la situation certains ici à washington
dire qu'il pourrait y avoir dix qui
pourrait y avoir des sanctions est
dirigée contre vladimir poutine on sait
aussi que les états unis ont récemment
redéployer des soldats qui se trouvaient
déjà en europe vers les pays baltes ils
ont le si un certain nombre de soldats
en pologne alors pour l'instant la
maison blanche assure qu'elle n'a pas
l'intention de combattre la russie et
washington dit que finalement ces
troupes qui sont aux frontières de
l'ukraine et bien sont prêtes à réagir
face à toute une série d'éventualités
notamment par exemple pour apporter de
l'aide humanitaire en cas de crise de
réfugiés voilà il ya une aussi une
réunion d'urgence des ambassadeurs de
l'otan qui va être organisée dans les
prochaines heures après le lancement de
cette opération militaire russe que
peut-on attendre de l'otan de cette
nouvelle réunion d'urgence
alors on peut attendre de l'otan
justement qu'elle prenne de nouvelles
mesures qu'elle annonce de nouvelles
sanctions et c'est sur ce point là aussi
qu'un 6 beaucoup les etats-unis ces
derniers temps c'est qu'il y ait un
message d'unité avec les alliés de
l'otan il pourrait y avoir aussi une
annonce faite de la part des états unis
d'un d'un nouveau redéploiement de
troupes qui se trouve déjà en europe on
sait que les états unis ont quelques 90
mille soldats en europe dont la moitié
de viron la moitié se trouve en allemand
et les etats unis assurent qu'ils
agiront de concert avec leurs alliés
c'est vraiment sur ce point là qu'il
insiste depuis le début que et c'est
pour ça aussi que ces dernières semaines
ils ont partagé plus de renseignements
que d'habitude avec leurs alliés
transatlantiques et avec le canada pour
tenter justement de répondre ensemble à
7,7 cesser cette attaque de la russie
gauthier rybinski s